- [Voiceover] The graph
above shows a number
of George's unsold candy
bars over a 10-day period.
The points on the graph all lie
on which of the following lines?
Let's see, as the days go
by he has fewer and fewer
unsold candy bars, all the
way until we get to day 10,
and he sold all of his candy bars,
'cause he has no unsold candy bars left.
But anyway, they want us to figure out
what could be the graph of the line,
or the points on the graph all lie
on which of the following lines?
Let's just think about
this line a little bit.
So when we're thinking about
any line, we could think about,
"Well, what's the slope
of this line going to be?"
So, let's see, our slope.
Our slope is our change
in our vertical-axis
for a given change in our horizontal-axis.
And so let's say that we pick the change
in our horizontal-axis
to be 10, 10 days go by.
So our change in our
horizontal-axis is 10 days,
and so what was the
change in our vertical?
Well, the change in our vertical
was 120 candy bars, or negative 120.
So we went down, when number
of days increased by 10,
positive 10, our candy
bars decreased by 120.
Decreased by 120, and so
what's that going to be?
That's going to be negative 12.
So we want to align with
a slope of negative 12,
and immediately when you look over here...
we could already start to
think about the y-intercept,
but immediately when you look over here,
the slope is going to be
the coefficient on the x.
So here this is a slope of
positive 10, that's not right.
Slope of positive 10, that's not right.
Slope of positive 12, not
negative 12, that's not right.
Slope of negative 10, that's not right.
And right over here, we
have our last choice,
slope of negative 12, so our choice is E.
But we could keep going even
if this was a free answer,
we could still figure
this out, because we know
that the slope of a line,
or the equation of a line,
is y is equal to your slope...
your slope times x,
plus your y-intercept.
Now we already figured out
that the slope right over here
is negative 12, and
what's our y-intercept?
Well, that's what y is equal
to when x is equal to zero.
When x is equal to zero,
when no days have gone by,
George has got 120 candy bars.
So this right over here
is going to be 120.
So the equation of our line is
going to be, y is equal to...
even if we didn't have these choices,
y is equal to negative 12 times x,
plus 120.
Or, you could obviously
swap these two around,
and write it as 120 minus 12x,
which is exactly what
they did right over here.